working for free on your terms versus
getting paid dick to pay your dues on
not terms it's not enclosed like a
visible and I see with clarity like my
name is Jerry Tom but I've been telling
you how accountant celebrity I'll triple
a given a pedigree to mean an especial
my faculties I'm putting the works and
I'm getting are the morning guys
100 pieces
morning this makes it what is she doing
stuff that's what's once in my money I'm
gonna try to figure that out
[Music]
here's what I would say to just
triple-reinforced so we're getting it
through the system see jump in if when
I'm done if you want to add anything to
this I'm very very excited that I think
I pushing through the system we get a
brief and we go to our version of the
30-second spot which is a Facebook
commercial and then influencer marketing
campaign both by the way for that that
to me feels as right as anything we've
done since it's $20,000 a month to 40
you get Twitter pictures you get
Facebook comment be like it's the most
scalable winnable it feels very right to
me and I want to continue to push the
organization in that way okay awesome
[Music]
pressure that vision I got black just
like I was trying to sing and I will
give my attention to it 100% when I
write in a moment
and I will kind of dissect at heart how
it will put my brain car into it and I
kind of move on to the next thing this
one okay so they make squirrel or Monica
are you able to come part so I think I'm
like that
but what I think has made me successful
is I've always had one big pillar it's
kind of like eating a burger but always
having different complements to it I
think a lot of people just eat the
potato or the pickle the onion order man
a sort of mayonnaise and mayo or the
ketchup or the jalapeno but they never
eat the burger like I have the burger
Wine Library vaynermedia my personal
brand ever my name is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this looks of 241 of the askgaryvee
show investing those are my burgers I
feel really hearing people think this I
mean he covers this this is insane
I have no time for me to be spending 49
minutes on this it's so [ __ ] crazy
it makes zero sense but it fits in
McGary be brand killer I believe in it
but it is me being a DB doubt what I
think you need to figure out is you've
got to create at least one burger I've
got four right you need to have one if
you feel you don't I don't know yet but
that's the analogy
right because what the burger does is
allows you to create the wealth creation
or the financial stability that allows
you to go firm I don't think people
realize is by documenting and
communicating on a daily basis as you
build an audience that is just
interested in people reality TV f-scale
it opens up business development
opportunities you never know when you're
going to write something or say
something in a video six years now that
unlocks a leader that wants to see you
climb one of the most important of one
of the great stars of last 20 years came
in here a couple hours ago they came to
me off the documenting and creating and
people think I'm pulling it off enough
killing it off like I'm leaving millions
of dollars on the table each year by
being me now I'm getting some too but
it's a real like most unless you work
for yourself
and you're playing the longest game of
all time it's not recommended really
like what I sign that all in my mind
chained together everything everything
busy with the piano director's doing the
personal stuff using a lot of your
strategy the health of the bench man
you're trying to go to freakin you on it
yeah time for him and this is as much
for you as everybody's watching because
I can just a new thought I have Mike and
gives a lot of do rocks like I think a
lot of people seem to Rock and we know
what I pay him and like well [ __ ] I
can't do that I have to do this I
actually don't think that's true I
actually think there are thousands of
people that are watching this way now
and even if you didn't have the
serendipity and luck of being here and
now we actually come to you in the
comments of dailyvee you're going to get
this I think that there's just like if I
were you and more importantly 10,000
people watching right now for the best
advice they should go to youtube they
should spend a month find 5959 437
people making video content who have
very few subscriptions be brought could
have been ads somebody couldn't email
them and said I can't believe in your
talent come and be my partner come and
document me I'm gonna be like that
believe in me I think you can sell
people on that I would believe you let
alone 500 people who just want to be
artists and we just want to do it and
who want to be nomads too so that's
another thing to think
man if you can't afford it I just
generally understand there are it's a
supply and demand game when people get
mad about working for free they don't
understand it's all supply and demand
like no no hardcore amazing computer
developer work for free any more
consistent maybe when there are
unlimited kids filming and a court
listen if you're Steven Spielberg okay
let go but like before you're that
there's I mean where do you think you
know it's so funny working for free
working for free on your terms versus
getting paid dick to pay your dues I'm
not terms it's not enclosed no you mean
this lack of casing it's fun right come
look how are you sick granny marketing
of course VA services only does the game
really mark like maintain both in
September so I'm mr. good luck
manipulation I'm a page is my public
figure wonderful million verified okay
Facebook for people people that's why
you know mostly mindful really lucky
requests for planes I mean listen I
think you're in a great place right
Instagram is what I care about right now
you're in a space that I care about
we're doing a ton of influencer
marketing I think I think that this is
exactly why doing the right thing is the
right thing you know there's a billion
people that are emailing less every day
to meet with me I'm not mean with kids
am I reading with you for kicks and
giggles I'm eating because you're
handsome
meaning you because you've done
something right in a space that I care
about
that's a mysterious all right let me
welcome like the Fosters [ __ ] awesome
you just have to be mentally prepared
you need like right now you should be
building your business to pay 20 percent
big to the platform now what you can
also do is depending on what your
strategy is is start building outside of
platform or to me you're more it's more
important that you're just not the most
thing on [ __ ] Instagram like
interim and Facebook are the Beast of
the world but I don't know come on look
look look what have a snapchat like you
know like who the [ __ ] knows VR like you
just never want to you at the mercy of
everybody who's ever been at the mercy
of
being organic SEM first result on Google
or email or is never want to be poor see
anything shits about to hit the fan
I think it's amantha miss here so this
is the right time to move this is
actually where's the real like eighty
billion dollars into television
commercials where they condemn money is
going go to you so I think like the
question becomes like what business you
want to build awesome
good to see you goodness how are you a
real pleasure
how are you think of how are you real
pleasure how you guys doing it's good
it's coming in Tumbo your wolf yeah so
what I just recently in lat
we have we Congress been involved in a
social media world kind of deaf going to
be MIT from wanted how to acting
background want to raise in Florida new
to LA and omics 17 chase patrol dream
come backwards to even get that your
notorious yep looks like you know I'm a
lot closer place I became the one that
plays dick yes so may not relate your
players but yes exact opposite analogy
hateful for who you know not lying that
became the man pepper understand very
much there it's funny I had Rudy
Nicholas Jerome Britney all all of them
and I said none of you know what's going
to happen in a year and they were like
so funny about it and it was because I
lived it with YouTube and Twitter the
generations before they're just I get it
for sure that makes a lot of sense so if
I was like your brother and partner I'd
be like man listen to me like you know
have been right since we were kids about
where the world's going let's write a TV
show let's do it on Facebook and let's
stay the course so like I don't want CIA
for propagate or end evolved to have
control over you you actually have a lot
of leverage
so the question becomes how do you under
write it so as long as you can sell a
brand or an investor you're good and
then you just got to be patient and
lived it you've lived building more Fame
in that world that is parlayed into it
like you know they play together you can
be agnostic and in one world view of
leverage and another world you don't so
for me it's like quadruple down on the
leverage to get you maybe you know you
know this man's do you notice do you
know this man
you better know you better know yeah
hold on you get cosine cosine shape hi
how are you
I'm rainy such a pleasure Brittany how
are you oh man a real pleasure for you
I'm guessing for a man in general where
do you see that going job this year and
you know three four years on our brand
utilizing no more yeah but it's a supply
demand issue there'll be more money in
there'll be more competition yeah so
it's a marketplace so it's going to be a
really competitive marketplace but it's
gonna be a huge marketplace so like
Google AdWords for people that were
winning in two thousand one two and
three when I would give them the advice
that more people were coming they got
scared but like number you don't get it
it's going to go from one hundred
million dollar market to a four billion
dollar market as long as you're good as
long as you guys keep crushing your
contests you'll be fine like it's the
people that are in early subsidized
beachfront property and building a
shitty house like well that'd be worth
as much on the you're still on the beach
right so it still worth money but your
neighbor built a much nicer house so
that will go for eight million years
will go for four million
got it all right jacket cool thank you
economic crafts on everything to me
anytime
what's one better with where we do their
investor buying raisin bran
let's go through all the seven-figure
stuff that's been it all okay all right
let me know
see you later get them off kind of 9:00
at night trying to find my drinks
leading right now Texan Tyler my friend
Constantine meeting the business meeting
he says he's here I'm here good guys
busy huh but I was intense
my guy got a new bar for brother that
like no one pilot again how's that how's
everything at home everything's great
crazy right Oh overall there's my
partner in there reverse engineer your
truth it's all self-awareness and then
putting yourself in the position of
succeed too many people wish there's
something instead of realizing what they
are Celeste dreaming more practicality
but more dreaming in the context of
practicality right so you don't have to
be the prettiest or the smartest or the
best attack or the best singer like it's
about understanding like I was an
entrepreneur always I didn't know that
social media was going to come along and
like entrepreneurship was going to be
cool and people wanted to fix up
business I was who I was and the world
came to me you can't force yourself to
be an influencer you can't force
yourself to be a fashion so you can't
force yourself to be a food critic you
got to actually figure out what you are
and what you love and then go all-in on
that and then they will come to you
everybody's trying to go to where it's
going instead of you know then you're
just a flash in the pan plug itself
Congrats with everything at home
we're here to talk about culture we
always wake up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]